optimal at this altitude I can run flat
out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking can I ask you a personal
question
now see I'm a cybernetic organism living
tissue over metal endoskeleton this
episode is brought to you by me
undies if I'm not going commando I'm in
me undies I have been testing these
underwear for three to four months now
pretty much every day and in fact
throughout a bunch of my other underwear
this morning and on the road in the
house they are extremely comfortable
they look good feel good they are made
of micro Modell 2 times softer than
cotton as scientifically tested using
the kalibata method sounds very fancy of
course and I get a lot of compliments
from ladies for these you don't get
diaper but you don't get the tired
elastic band they look great and they
have underwear for both men and women
check out my undies com forward slash
Tim and you can see everything I've been
wearing they're ridiculous the sublime
everything between including my favorite
which is called out and I would be
remiss if I didn't mention their lounge
pants this is a new thing and I've been
wearing their lounge pants when I record
podcasts
I've been wearing them out and about
when I'm walking the dog meeting people
for coffee and they are extremely
comfortable they're made from the same
material as the underwear but some of
them like the blue ones I have have
pockets so you can walk about without
seeming like you're off of your meds and
completely crazy
so that is awesome and if you're not
happy with the first pair you try on I
assume that refers to the underwear
they'll refund you completely and you
can keep the pair you tried on for free
but if you're that kind of person you
should be ashamed because that's
disgusting me Andy's com4 slash Tim
check it out
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it investing service
led by technologists from places like
Apple and world-famous investors it has
exploded in popularity in the last two
years and they now have more than two
and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in
wealthfront so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the value of wealth front is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than ten asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealth front as I mentioned since
it's using software instead of retail
locations etc can offer all of this at
low costs that were previously
completely impossible right off the bat
you never pay commissions or account
fees for everything they charge 0.25
percent per year on assets above the
first 15,000 which is managed for free
if you use my link wealthfront com
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on the
show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealth
that I've invested a significant amount
of my own money at least for me in the
team and the company itself so I am an
investor and hope to soon use it as a
client now back to the recommendation as
a Tim Ferriss show listener you'll get
fifteen thousand dollars managed for
free if you decide to open an account
but just start with seeing the portfolio
that they would suggest for you take two
minutes fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront comm forward slash Tim it's
fast it's free there's no downside that
I can think of hello my fine feathered
friends is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
where it is my job each episode to
deconstruct world-class performers and
tease out the routines habits daily
rituals breakfasts favorite books
whatever it might be that you can
emulate test in your own life this
episode is a role reversal and a very
hilarious one at that Jamie Foxx is back
on the show this is around to where he
interviewed me for his radio show and we
simultaneously recorded for the podcast
it was great fun we recorded in his
studio at his home in Los Angeles for
those of you who didn't hear the first
appearance of Jamie on the podcast it
was voted 2015 podcast of the year last
year with producthunt and others the
title was Jamie Foxx on workout routines
success habits and untold Hollywood
stories you can check that out at 4-hour
workweek comm /j me and for those
interested the second-place runner-up
for podcasts the arrows also from the
Tim Ferriss show and that was navall
ravikant
if you haven't heard of him you gotta
learn all about him and that is 4-hour
workweek compilation of all nav al a few
things about this episode so it's cut up
into segments because we were taking
commercial breaks for the radio show
there are a number of songs that Jamie
comments on or refers to indirectly that
I couldn't play in this podcast due to
copyright reasons they are from say Oh
male melancia and one of the hottest
voices and faces ever that is Brazilian
Portuguese baby metal karate federico al
ballet esta noche
and then Sevendust splinter all of these
will be linked to in the show notes so
just go
for our workweek com4 slash podcast for
all the show notes on this episode and
every other episode and there are going
to be a couple of stories in here for
very long term listeners that you've
probably heard some variation of before
because people ask me about some of my
backstory etc there are definitely
things you have not heard before
including a Jamie's exploration of past
lives and it goes in many different
directions but I think you'll enjoy it
and at the very least listen to the
first few minutes because Jamie is the
consummate performer which is of course
what you would expect from someone who
is an Academy Award winning actor Grammy
award-winning musician and a famous
stand-up in improv comedian he has all
the tools in the toolkit you can say hi
to Jamie on twitter at IM jamie foxx two
x's and without further ado please enjoy
this raucous romp through the mind of
Jamie Foxx and yours truly if I told you
that Oprah Winfrey is now a white man if
I told you that Oprah Winfrey has now
become Caucasian what would you say I
got a chance to meet this man this man
literally changed my life my young
friend Ricardo who speaks seven
languages
he's a heartthrob he explained to me
about who this guy was you need to do
this guy's podcast and I was like really
because I was such I'm ancient when it
came to the internet when it came to
these things in social media I was so
far behind Ricardo would always say you
got to shake off the dust you know it's
like my parents whenever trying to
figure out a microwave and he brought
this guy in to my house and we did this
this incredible interview and literally
it was like I had a record out when I
left it was like I had a movie out when
I left I was getting stopped by people
of all walks of life I said Jamie I
don't necessarily like your [ __ ] but
what you did on this man show move me
Joe Rogan who I'm known from the from
from the comedy world
Ricardo sending me a clip of Joe Rogan
talking about this man I'm talking about
now 70 million downloads all right 70
million some of you guys don't even have
65 likes and you're constantly
constantly constantly posted you need to
get it together maybe you need his for
our plan I'm talking about none other
the Oprah Winfrey of the Internet ladies
and gentlemen turn the music out Tim Tim
how you doing baby I'm doing fantastic
so thanks thanks again for having me hey
I love this studio
okay listen million vibes in this great
vibes man listen all I could say is it I
cannot say enough of of who you are I
was in New York lawyers doctors all
walks of people came up to me and said
yo Jamie the Tim Ferriss interview like
took me over the moon and I was like I
was out you you know obviously record I
told me who you were all the research
can still cannot put into words what how
you impact the world where do you come
from
what are you doing since 1977 with it
you were born in 87 i was born 77 okay i
had time to pick up i was trying to
break in break into electric boogaloo ah
little cardboard Oh Long Island never
suddenly the song we just played is one
of Tim's top 5 songs what was naming it
song that is male volunteer by a singer
named sailor from Brazil but wow you
know what you made you make the foxhole
work too because I asked him for his
five songs and then he didn't give me no
iTunes [ __ ] he said getting them crates
getting those crates and luckily we have
a Cuban who's putting things together
and before Trump gets in office you know
we got a few anyway we got a few minutes
we'll talk about all that later on we
have a Tim Ferriss Tim what do you come
from it and and and how what gives you
the mindset now I've met you
you've interviewed me but like now
people want to know who you are like
where do you come from I was born and
raised on Long Island Wow rat tail and
all long guys strong Island strong I
about at the end and mom was physical
therapist dad a real estate broker local
real estate broker and my parents were
very good at encouraging me and my
younger brother that's the family to
explore and they always had they didn't
have a much budget for anything other
than books so that if we if we latched
on to something right they would take us
to say the remainder table at the
bookstore and find these discounted
books and yeah
and that is where I think a lot of the
experimentation started mostly because I
was very hyperactive as a kid but I was
a runt I was born premature and so my
mom got some good word from the other
the other ladies the other moms that kid
wrestling was a good place to exhaust
your kid we all said she threw me into
wrestling and I had no endurance because
if some lung issues and other issues so
I started getting very good in high
school at cutting weight and that's
where I started really studying the
human body in this obsession with self
experimentation took off
Wow self experiment to what what makes
you think that though I mean because is
what I say all the time it's like people
have gifts now everybody's given a gift
but what would make you think self
experimentation and how would that
manifest to what it is right now or did
you foresee that well I think that one
of the catalysts was a weakness that
turned into a strength so for cutting
weight I always sweat very easily which
meant that I could get dehydrated very
easily now that was a liability and a
problem and so many other sports but in
wrestling right I'm trying to cut down
to a lower weight class it was a huge
advantage I can I could lose water
weight very quickly well and so I
started thinking well if that's the case
that this weakness can be turned into a
strength where else can I find a
Keeley's heels that I can turn into
advantages and it just led me to be a
bit more analytical than I suppose some
of the other kids who were normal and
then I could compete in the normal way I
just couldn't do that right and I also
had a very
Winchell coach wrestling coach mr.
buckston who was I think a rarity in
today's climate at least he was a
hard-ass who like cared enough to really
beat your ass yeah that's the old-school
term we don't have it no more you can't
touch the kids no my father was a freak
was a was a teacher for 20 years can't
test kids I wouldn't be able to I
wouldn't be able to cover an essay so he
whooped your ass huh oh yeah I mean we
would and I just remember one practice
we had these drills and they're called
blood circles or some of the horrible
some some horrible name and mr. bucks I
don't think I can do it I don't think I
can do it he's not only a successful
coach I mean he was a tri varsity
athlete in college and exceptional
athlete and coach but he was also very
good at teaching he was a teacher
English teacher I believe and an
incredible fundraiser for the school so
he was multi-talented now he's the Dean
of Culver
Academy military academy in Indiana but
I remember at one point Oh sack mr.
buckston I can't do it anymore I'm gonna
puke and he's like he's like that's what
the bucket over there is for Wow go over
there and puke and then come back and
continue the drill
Wow and what what was great about that
environment although I didn't realize it
at the time and is that he pushed all of
us past the point that we felt was our
limit and if you look at the kids who
are in that wrestling team like my
wrestling partner guy named Charles best
who was a year ahead of me always beat
me by one point rest rest loss for the
varsity spot where as Charles Mann so
Charles is the CEO and founder of a
nonprofit called DonorsChoose which is a
huge educational nonprofit that has
people like Oprah Winfrey and Stephen
Colbert and all these supporters huge
massive success that's changing the
world and he also credits a lot of his
success back to mr. box to the coach
steel sharpest steel it's Jamie Fox Fox
already you know how we get down series
96 wheel with the Oprah Winfrey of the
Internet we with the open his podcast is
number one he's breaking it down on how
he learned what self experimentation was
he tells us that his coach which I still
credit my coach coach heizak my seventh
grade coach who gave me
Lix if my grace was on gaming licks if I
got caught outside you know he may she
was this he's given us building blocks
but talk about this when you say there
was a problem can you speak on what it
was you had a long situation yeah I had
so my lung collapsed
when I was born and I think I had five
total blood transfusions so I was in the
ICU as a young kid and so I was I still
scars on the left side of my chest and
then my wrist here looks kind of like a
cigarette burns down a cigarette I was
about that's from its being intubated
and so even to this day I'm very very
sensitive to heat and have a lot of
issues with the even heat stroke and a
few occasions where I've had to be
hospitalized and I just my brain just
doesn't function turns off it has a set
point where these things called heat
shock proteins and whatnot get triggered
at a relatively low temperature compared
to other folks right so so you guys say
cool I have to say cool yeah gotta stay
cool stay cool stay cool yeah yeah it
almost sound like a superhero it's like
a it's like do remember I'm breakable
yeah yeah it's almost like wow you take
these things it's like he's a superhero
he's able to be he's able to to to give
you for our planet but don't let him
well he don't let him in the Sun
definitely weak in the Sun yeah you can
see I'm not I look like the underbelly
of I don't know manatees I saw a lot
bright and they're you know my girls
came through well I think what of if you
know so I was a comic book nerd grown-up
so I write I collected comics and a
favor come Wolverine
Wow because Wolverine was human he was
human yes pecan is bigger Wolverine and
the Punisher so I was in other words I
was I was fans of the human comic-book
heroes who had found strengths or
augmented strengths like Superman's like
hey you were born that way hey yeah but
Batman like you had to build yeah all
the tools around him so that appealed to
me is kind of a tinkerer and you know
even to this day the I trace it all back
to these physical problems that I had as
a kid
and for instance this is about let's say
five five or ten years ago I did
experiment at Stanford University there
I found out that they were doing
research on heat tolerance for soldiers
and I was like oh this is a chance for
me to gather data on myself and figure
out why my brain turns off and so the
experiment was terrible what they had us
do is that have to put an esophageal
probe down my nose so this is a piece of
plastic that's about two feet long you
put it through your nostril down your
throat to your heart level to measure
your core body temperature and then you
then you tape it so it doesn't get lost
and then you take another one and you
stick it up the other end because what
does it mean you stick it up your ass
okay up to your heart that direction Wow
so because the military wants of that
data yeah and then you put on a full
military out like full military gear
weighted backpack helmet everything you
go into a hundred and I think was four
degree sauna and March on an incline
treadmill to exhaustion until you've
basically have heat struggle you so you
have something up your ass and up your
note and down your nose this is going
all out no wonder you you you know your
[ __ ] to be with literally uh uh
and then you did this I did and what
they were testing was a glove that you
stuck your hand into this glove and it
would create a vacuum around your wrist
and then circulate cold water around a
metal cylinder that you grabbed and the
theory was you could use that to rapidly
cool your body temperature so they
wanted to develop it for soldiers right
and it was being tested at the time by
some very very good boxers very very
good athletes so that was that was all
it took for me to volunteer to do it I
only did about four sessions I was like
after the four session oh so more times
of it going alright yeah I got yes I got
like I've had enough of this yeah did
you smoke a cigarette after hey ladies
and gentlemen Jamie Foxx boxer radio is
Sirius XM 96 we're going to take a break
up we coming right back and find out how
he went from that to be in the top
person on the Internet
this is another song that he loves
another one bites the dust Tim Ferriss
we're back in a moment
Sirius XM 96 self-experimentation
leading up to being one of the most
sought after the number one
I cast in the world I'm here with none
other than the incredible the remarkable
superhero superhero Tim Ferriss in the
building how you doing man
better and better better better so take
me through it
take me through going through the
through the experiments finding out what
you want to do up until 4-hour workweek
sure so the the trajectory was but get
me to that but just don't go straight
today oh no I got you there I'll get you
there you know was where'd you where'd
you where'd you find this niche well I
think there were a couple things so I
had an opportunity my sophomore year in
high school to go abroad for the first
time there was an exchange program that
was available to me and I had never
spent really any time outside the United
States you know Niagara fall maybe
crossed over in Canada all right but
went to Japan for a year and lived with
Japanese families went to a Japanese
school I was the only at one point the
only you know the only white kid only
American kid at school 5,000 Japanese
kids Wow
school uniforms and everything so I was
completely immersed in that culture for
a year and it what it showed me is how
arbitrary a lot of our rules are really
meaning like we drive on one side of the
street they drive on the other we we
take showers a certain way they share
bats but you have to take a shower
before you get in the bath and the whole
family uses the same bathwater
from some kind of spiritual what is it's
it's a just a Japanese cultural
tradition or food oh they're these deep
soaking bats and they go in order of
seniority so it's like Grandma gets to
go in first
Wow then dad then mom then the siblings
from oldest to youngest so it's like if
you're the youngest kid you get you get
the dregs I mean you know that you get
all you get grandma's oh yeah you got
grandma's you blown around it's it's
it's a trip so on granny
I don't thats not an exaggeration I was
like yeah is this so so you get in after
the whole family oh yeah so I mean I
would get in actually before the
youngest brother because I was all done
anyway but but the point being that it
it showed me that our rules were very
arbitrary a lot of our rules are just
kind of socially reinforced and that
is room to improvise you can negotiate
those things you can experiment you can
be different you can March to your own
drummer and when I came back I finished
high school and ended up going to
college in New Jersey I went to
Princeton undergraduate and first
studied neuroscience and then
transferred to East Asian Studies we're
focused on Japanese Chinese and Korean I
was mostly focused on the languages and
language and why that why do you feel it
was that what is it the certain
disciplines that they have or when you
went over there you felt something that
made you change like so sort of like
when I went to Africa like there was
this thing that I felt like it was from
I said wow I feel this amazing thing and
Mozambique and I stood it you know in
the ocean and I was like oh I feel this
thing is that the same you know x2 the
first year the first person is kind of
dug into this uh yes I did feel
something when I was there and you know
I want to go as far to say like oh my
god maybe in a past life instead of the
other thing when I was there what foot
for up for us on our show yeah please do
that because we don't we don't we don't
want to you know we we don't skims you
if you really felt that I'll jump right
into it you know I did I did and to the
extent that you know some of my closest
friends when I got into Judo and I was
training in different martial arts there
and so on they would say oh I team all
my ninja now they would insist they're
like you're Japanese you're not American
you're Japanese and I don't get it
that's weird
well so they would always I mean there's
an expression which is just like strange
foreign or hidden ID and then smear my
hand like I didn't know then there just
go on and on help me say that what you
say is so strange walking know how does
it so if you want to say strange
foreigner yeah it's henna in that guy
Jean K Jean
yeah hinder guys you know gadget so if
you wanted to like if you're hanging out
some Japanese people and then some non
Japanese did something funny you just
wait till I walked off and look at them
again Scott and that guy gene in that
Katie I'm just hanging out with some
rappers and I don't like they saw in
that guy see that but here's the thing
like but but but speak on that spiritual
thing because I think I think that is
really real yeah and and we've talked
you know we were at a party mix you
express something about you know coyotes
and things like that but speak speak on
that that you felt something
and in Japan I felt like in a lot of
ways I was returning home to a place I
had never been which is an odd feeling
to have but the simplicity the striving
for elegance and the way they use
negative space for instance just the way
that you'll have certain rooms in the
house that are extremely uncluttered
that are used for they have altars they
have tatami rooms and it just struck a
chord with me
and I felt like I was returning to
something but of course I had never even
been there previously and the quite
frankly a lot of the strict rules that
they socially enforced so you have for
instance in the judo club you have and
this can go wrong right I'm not saying
all of its good but no no you have you
have simp I which like the upperclassmen
and then you have kohai which like the
lower classmen and it's very
hierarchical right you do what the
senpai tell you to do but it was what I
really enjoyed about it and what I had
not really had because I was the oldest
sibling in my family was like they'll
beat your ass right but I no one else is
allowed to beat your ass oh yeah I mean
it was a very kind of older brother type
of relationship but I was always the
oldest so I hadn't I'd ever experienced
that and I found just like tremendous
comfort in that and right in in a large
to to a large extent and it wasn't easy
to understand culture also I think in
the u.s. right now people are prone not
to say what they mean and I'll come back
to that in a second okay and there's so
much political correctness and wow I
want to get into that yeah I want to get
in a median I want to get in right as a
comedian and everybody is concerned with
upsetting everyone else's feelings
whereas in Japan once you get past what
they call pot they might as a thought
they might like what you put forward to
other people and then Holden is what you
really feel right and only if you speak
Japanese people like oh my god Japanese
people they never say what they mean I'm
like that's [ __ ] you just don't
speak Japanese like if you speak the
language they'll let you in constant
lease and then the shoes you got on
and it's I just found it a very
refreshing culture in the sense that
there were rules that had worked for
them for thousands of years and not all
positive things came from them but it I
did feel oddly familiar to me wow wow
that's amazing because you say that
quite frankly or maybe it could have
been a past life we did it we did a
great radio interview with Quentin
Tarantino honey and we talked about how
he used the n-word how you use the word
and I wanted to get him on because you
know a lot of black folks you know
especially deal with all the things with
Oscars all these different things about
you know that word and why Quentin turn
to and he said before we got on the
radio and he also said on red I felt
that in my past life I was actually a
black man and when he said that it was
no ho keenest it was actually you know
you believe it because he spoke with
conviction so so talk about do you think
that there that we do live past lies and
all right or is it selective I you know
I I don't rule it out I mean it's I
don't have any evidence for it right but
my experience in Japan was quirky enough
and just felt deep and real enough that
there seems to be more to the story
right and and even even to the extent
and of course there are alternate ways
to explain this but I had trouble
learning Spanish then I went to Japan
and I picked up Japanese like a snap of
the fingers Wow
and and there were challenges but even
the characters and so on came to me very
naturally nothing I was part of a visual
memory but it was a transformative
experience so that that year abroad sort
of informed and changed the trajectory
of my life Wow completely Wow and the
way that I related to American culture
and to thinking of myself and to
thinking of what was you know
quote-unquote
real or realistic I was like well here's
a culture that works just fine yeah and
it's totally different like rules of
engagement the rules of interrelating
are totally different so what's to
prevent me from taking those and bring
them back to the u.s. or just trying to
find
option C right right and so I think that
is also something that opened my eyes to
just asking what if questions like well
what if I did this that no one else is
doing right what's the worst thing that
could happen what's the downside let me
try it and test test test test test
right it's Jamie Foxx Fox no radio we
get in deep right now it's Fox a radio
series 96 if you don't know you better
know Tim Ferriss right now go to his
podcast right now he is the number one
podcast in the world seventy billion
downloads 70 billion we're closing
Mergener billion bill 70 million but you
know what I'm saying we on our way there
uh he is considered the Oprah Winfrey of
audio podcast we're going to get to that
we're going to get to that let me keep
on with this you said something about
the political and correctness you said
something what are we going through
right now in the world because there I I
do feel that there's a fine line me as a
comedian I've always you know I've been
put on this earth for that I've been put
on this earth to look at what is funny
no matter what whether it was Christian
whether it was Muslim where it's fat
skinny tall short that is my license but
right now in America we're going through
something that is incredibly weird
especially when I talked to Jay Leno
I talked to rock Chris Rock who had a
very very tough time um landing at the
Oscars which was tough I thought it was
a toughest job in the world for him to
have to do because we want to respect
Jada pinkett-smith in that sense but at
the same time we have to do our jokes
because it but and it put him in this
weird thing what what's what do you
think we should do since you to open
we're free coming we're coming to you
right now
Tim put us in the right in the right
light like what do we need to be I think
we should worry about helping people and
not placating people Wow Wow I think I
think we should concern ourselves with
speaking truth and not glad-handing and
that's easier said than done of course
but I really feel that I've said this to
friends of mine in close conversation
where I live
Valley before that I feel like comedians
are the only people right now who can
speak truth right right and it's just
like the court jester back in the day it
was like the court jester could speak
truth to the King anyone else and have
their head lopped off
yeah and that person had license and my
feeling is hopefully we can expand that
we need to expand that because I've
noticed among some of my most
intelligent most incisive most
influential friends they've just opted
out of the conversation because they're
afraid of getting chased by the lynch
mob so to speak for saying anything that
is truth and that's a dangerous trend
that's a very dangerous trend and I just
mention one more thing which is there's
a book that a lot of people read in high
school called Fahrenheit 451 and these
firemen run around and they burn books
and if you ask anyone who's read the
book but hasn't read it in like 20 years
what do you remember of of how that came
to be in the book they'd say oh there's
this totalitarian government the truth
is it was the people it was the people
who decided that any dissenting opinions
that would offend specific groups in
society ought to be burned it so is
self-inflicted Wow and I think that's
what we're doing right now is we are
slowly torching the First Amendment and
free speech by basically just going on
these witch hunts right and I think I
think it's the most dangerous thing in
the u.s. right now yeah and here's the
thing hissing and I think what's also
dangerous too is it's sometimes the
wrong people sometimes the wrong people
bring the message without mentioning any
names but sometimes it makes it hard
when other people go so far and it ain't
funny you don't say like like like I
always say like this yeah we could say
whatever we want to say as long as you
have it wrapped up in some sort of funny
or something that gives us a little
caveat of I care about you yeah I'm
gonna talk about you I did a joke about
a Bruce Jenner early on but the reason
in my joke the reason that the joke was
there is because in comedy if we are all
equal then that means everybody gets
equal jokes like I can't do the black
joke and then not do - why
joke there was a situation when I had to
do I had I had to host this this uh I
had to host this award show and uh they
went through and they looked at all
about jokes and all the jokes that were
for african-americans they were old man
that is hilarious
but then the ones that weren't for
african-americans which was you know
some of the the white people who thought
they had a hard time with and I was like
listen I was like listen I said we have
to do it all across the board straight
gay black white we have to give
everybody an opportunity to get in and
they were so nervous about me doing me
just but when we went out and did him
even the people that we were talking
about came up and said all man we loved
it because it felt like they were part
of the party and and it was sort of like
I said you gotta trust the comedian that
yeah it's gonna hurt a little bit and I
asked his I'll ask you this question I
sure
when is the joke is when do you laugh at
a joke your hardest when when it's the
most uncomfortable when it's not about
you yeah okay there we go
well you laugh oh man and Japanese do be
doing it yeah man Mexicans do be doing
it is a black be but a man why are you
going to us like that it's just soda I
want to take I want to take a break I'm
going to come back to that just to tie
that up because I really want to get
your take on it not my take on it on how
we can navigate now through a world
where we've gone to politically-correct
have we and then how do we not go too
far on the other side without putting
something there that that's in you know
that makes sense if it makes it we're
here with Tim Ferriss it's FOXO serious
right here you better tune in right now
get your life right cuz he's gonna come
in after this and tell you how to get
your life together in four hours
serious 96 J Fox Fox Oh we'd be right
back to what is this what isn't for the
song this is a baby metal karate huh
baby metal karate baby this was going to
be in the playlist as Tim Ferriss that's
Tim Ferriss this box o radio series 96
we are getting nourished right now we're
not just having a radio show we're
getting nerve
with with with with our minds we were
just talking before we went to break we
were talking about political correctness
has it become too much and you were
saying that you were talking about
Daniel Tosh and it was I was because I
think that he is if you look at his head
shot like this is this is a guy who you
wouldn't expect to step out and bring
some of the comedy that he does and I
call at one point before he was I think
was before tosh point-o but when he was
doing stand-up and what I appreciated
was how uncomfortable he made every yeah
and I just remember this one bit and
that will be a point to this but you
know he opened it up with I wonder if
people taste like their ethnic cuisine
and I'm gonna Massacre the bed is like
Nestle everybody's I can like like black
people black be like do they taste like
fried chicken
oh and then everyone's like oh I don't
know if I should laugh it on if there's
no no I'll get you don't worry he's like
Chinese people kung pao chicken hahaha
and then everybody starts loosening it
up in there laugh and laugh and laugh
but audience about 50 percent white and
then he's like and white people he's
like now we don't need white people
uh-huh and so they didn't get the alga
they did it out yeah runs like oh my god
is it okay laugh is not okay and I think
that I think it was may West who said
you know those who are offended easily
should be offended more often yeah and
of that and I think that in the u.s.
right now we were just talking on break
about how the internet I think is it's a
great tool but it's like a knife it cuts
both ways yeah and it can be used for
harm or could be harmed used for good
and when every genius but every idiot
has a voice they're all there I'm are
you a genius or an idiot
yeah it's the new t-shirt and everyone
has a voice but I think in that
environment what we've seen is that you
could take you can sacrifice
unfortunately some people who could
really contribute to society if they if
they slip up and say one stupid thing
which we all say but they'll get lynched
not by their peers necessarily but
people who aren't in a position and
shouldn't be in a position to judge them
and so what I would say is that we have
a term social justice warrior that's
used for people who are just on the
internet constantly saying you can't say
that you know like here still we're
talking about like college campuses and
talk about Wales like your way
man doing where I'm doing a college
thing and assessing my Wales and your
Welsh aiming we couldn't do it a joke on
on one of the things about sharks
because some some singer said she's
doing the shark campaign to save the
sharks and they shut us down we couldn't
tell shark joke that's unbelievable it
to me it so and what what do we do I'm
cuz I'm gonna let you talk I'll yeah
what I think that what one of the ways
we could stem this tide is because I
feel like there are a lot of people who
can contribute to society and we're all
flawed human beings we're all going to
make mistakes we're all going to say
stupid things that shouldn't remove your
ability to contribute to society right
even if you even if let's just say
you're not let's say somebody does say
something racist or sexist or fill in
the blank if they're doing incredibly
valuable work like that they shouldn't
have to resign from their job
necessarily for that now I mean of
course it's the question of degree but
what I would say is one of the ways I
think we need to stem the tide is by
using language because that's the weapon
that's being used to to sort of mute
freedom of speech in other words if
someone says fill in the blank pissed
they can they can shut you down they can
end your comedy show well right now we
don't have a term to apply to those
people who cry wolf too often and do
unmitigated damage so what if instead of
social justice warrior which sounds
actually net positive there was a term
the one that I thought of was bigoted
ear so bigoted ear is someone who tries
to be a profiteer by calling other
people bigots and all of a sudden those
people will have a consequence for
crying wolf and falsely accusing people
loosely so I think that little bit that
language is one of the key pieces in
this arsenal because the problem itself
is a problem of language so so I'm just
see where where it'll go and also I
would just implore people comedians and
other people who are in a position where
perhaps they're say self employed so
they don't have or they don't perceive
as many risks as someone who's in like a
tight corporate structure speak your
mind
right right and Ryan and really
recognize that the downside in most
cases is being judged by people you
shouldn't care about and pressing in the
first place right right
right so please are people out there who
just like me they're people out there
who just want to do that like you know I
mean sometimes people tell me about what
you function with a seer by chance and I
don't really get into but he's racist
nobody dates white girl there's a
Trayvon but in he but he's gay he did I
said may you can't keep up with all of
these things that people and then if you
say one thing I've always been this even
even in the toughest situations where
there's been situations where either
something's been said about black folks
or someone's been saying about people
that I care about
I've always been leery of someone saying
something and you taking everything away
from them I remember it was a I don't
know if it was Don Imus I remember who
it was but I believed myself and Howard
Stern were on the same page we won the
same I'm at first our huge Howard Stern
fan like huge fan of his Howard Stern
has made his living his whole life I
mean it you know Don Rickles 2.0 if you
would and and we've said some of the
wildest [ __ ] on our show and on his show
but I never thought that someone should
be shut completely down if we say
something we had to own up to Miley
Cyrus we did something that was that she
was 16 I didn't know who she was a time
we did jokes it was you know we did that
type of jokes we you know we would be
considered a black Howard Stern and once
my daughter candid why would you do that
daddy the head of my channel I was like
who was Hannah Montana and we didn't
know but we didn't make a mistake but
what we did was we put ourselves on
punishment
we went down for however many weeks and
then we came back we made up policies
because you know it you know it was we
offended people at that time but what we
asked was don't let us close shot don't
let us put away our art our comedy
swords because that's what we're here to
do and the interesting about jokes is if
half the room goes oh and have some
laughs that's usually a successful
successful outing with jokes definitely
and I and I think that
for those people interested you know one
of the biggest assets and resources for
me over the last decade or so has been
stoic philosophy and so Marcus Aurelius
and Seneca is very old but it's actually
surprisingly easy to read and the
objective of stoic philosophy is to give
you basically an operating system for
making better decisions in life without
being reactive and I think that we we
suffer from an illusion in the u.s.
which is that comfort will bring
happiness and so we want to close our
sphere of comfort if that makes sense
whereas much we should want to expand
our sphere of comfort by exposing
ourselves to things that are
uncomfortable but I suppose on ourselves
to opinions we dislike exposing
ourselves to I mentioned I was fasting
for last few days yeah exposing myself
to hunger so that I don't fear being
hungry so then if I'm in an airport I'm
like oh I haven't eaten in six hours I
should really have a Big Mac no you
don't need to eat you can Wow you can go
as long as you need to without eating
and developing a resilience and strength
in that and I think that if it's very
important and you see this in for
instance where I live Silicon Valley a
lot because I've been involved with tech
for a long time but you have to make
mistakes and you have to make frequent
mistakes in order to learn and innovate
Wow and language is the the the
underlying foundation of all of that so
like you said if someone makes a mistake
and you close up shop that is the
fastest way to end learning innovation
pushing the envelope and healing a lot
of wounds I mean it because you you take
these issues and you just shove them
under the surface you don't get rid of
them right by muting someone right right
yeah exactly right but because of
someone because I would always say like
your your your your taking someone out
of the equation who really can help you
like there are really racist people
there are really bigoted people out
there but the comedian and in folks who
are just you know like like like that
was a situation like like I'll talk
about this cuz it's already out there
and she's a good friend of uh but it was
Amy Pascal and Amy Pascal and it was an
internet email thing and people just
went berserk
Oh God she's burning crosses she got she
got a white sheet in the back of her
Mercedes and I'm like bro look at the
amount of movies that she's done that
are african-american in Elijah's here
she could tell you she was the only one
doing african-american film you know now
you take something that was out of
context if if they caught me in my house
talking about other races oh man I
wouldn't be able to go to Laos I
wouldn't be able I would talk about
everybody y'all said but she was a great
person when it came to doing
african-american movies now she's not
there
yeah so now who you got you know so I
was like be careful on slinging that
type of rhetoric around too much because
a lot of people that are out there are
gonna like I said you're gonna make a
mistake every once in a while but like I
said you shouldn't like you know throw
him overboard its foxhole radio serious
96-well here with Tim Ferriss
he's given us the tools when I tell you
that Oprah Winfrey is now a white man
and he's on the internet his name is Tim
Ferriss 70 trillion downloads on his
podcast and I'm gonna read what it says
so people don't be like all Jaime hogs
are saying over went through dating the
white man no what I'm saying is how Tim
Ferriss became the Oprah of
audio how did you get it how did you
let's get into it now tech world you
said a tech well how does one get into
it so I mean I moved to the the Bay Area
to move to the the San Francisco area
after college and just in time for
everything to implode so I moved there
ninety nine I was the second to lowest
paid aside from the secretary at the
startup company they've made a mistake
they sent out an Excel spreadsheet and
one of the tabs is everybody's
compensation that was a big mistake I
made everybody upset but in any case
that company imploded and I found myself
on the west coast and I was surrounded
by tech so I was in the middle of the
switchboard and so I I decided to become
involved because I'd built some
companies prior to that in advising and
investing in startups and the way I
looked at it I think this is a helpful
way to look at a lot of things is I
originally as context I have fantasized
about going to Stanford Business School
there's a whole host of reasons but I'd
always felt like I was kind of intended
to go to Stanford it was a beautiful
campus the palm trees didn't go and I
was like I need to go there for business
school and I applied twice I went
through the process and I didn't go uh
because it was too theoretical and what
I ended up deciding was okay I'm going
to take the money that I would have had
to pay for Business School and I'm going
to put it into investing in startups and
that's going to be my MBA so I'm going
to over two years the same space of time
I'm going to invest small checks in
these startups and my assumption is I'm
going to lose all the money so I
shouldn't use money that I can't afford
to lose so over that period of time I
was looking at it as education so it's
like what can I invest in where I will
learn a lot like what kind of what kind
of startup can I invest in where I'll
have the opportunity to interact with
people who will average me up right one
piece of advice I was given when I was
in my teens that I found probably the
most useful of any was you're the
average of the five people you associate
with most so I was like alright how can
I use these small bets to associate with
higher and higher caliber of person and
I did that over the span of two years
and I didn't lose all the money a couple
of them worked and civ ended up
investing in Twitter Facebook Buber and
many others so that was the beginning of
my relationship in tech and helping some
of these startup founders in very
particular ways but the audio came about
the podcast because I was burned out on
books really yeah I was totally burned
out on books at this terrible habit of
writing long books so they're 400 to 700
pages long and I was so the first book
my first book was 420 pages as a 4-hour
workweek that came out too then seven
nobody expected it to do anything
I had an initial print run of 12,000
copies and I it hit the New York Times
list largely thank-thanks too early
adoption by tech folks and it stayed
there for for more than four years
unbroken and nobody expected that to
happen so I remember my my at my editor
my editor called me at the time at
Heather and I remember I got the call
she goes I was exhausted because I was
doing some like radio junket somewhere
in a satellite radio you know these
things you like sit there with like a
pitcher coffee yeah 30 radio interviews
I just finished us how exhausted and she
called she goes hey there mr. New York
Times bestselling author and I was like
what and she goes you hit the list and I
was like Heather don't [ __ ] with me not
right now please right I can't do it
she's like no you hit the list and it
was just so unexpected and so surreal
you feel man I leaned back against the
wall isn't room by myself because
everybody had left it was like 6 p.m. on
the East Coast and just kind of slid
down the wall and just like sat there
and I didn't know what to think I'm an
kid with the collapse long yeah yeah I
was a young kid whoo-hoo body
temperature gets heated up and whose
brain shuts down brain shuts down and
also you got a best-seller yeah it was
uh I would literally blank like I just I
couldn't even conceive of it being real
it's kinda like waking up from a dream
and you're like I was just a dream so it
took me a long time to even begin to
conceive of how that yet process how
that would affect my life
but it opened the door to writing more
so I never plan on being a writer in
fact I decided after college I didn't
want to write because I found it so
painful hmm and so I think like like
many people maybe that you know
certainly people I know they create
things because they're scratching their
own itch like they have to create it
yeah or it'll drive them crazy and so
writing was like that for me and but the
audio came about because I did the three
books and I just found myself burned-out
right I felt like I'd been using the
same talk about the three books so we
have four hour work week which was
really a collection of completely so for
our listeners Ryan Anna's listen Fox
already owe Sirius 96 get into what four
hour work week is the four hour work
week is a book that focuses on my
studies of different entrepreneurs and
case studies of my own different
experiments looking at how you can 10x
your hourly output and once you control
that currency known as time you can do
all sorts of interesting things like
travel so talks about low-cost travel it
talks about geo arbitrage where you
might say outsource things to a
different country and very interesting
ways to design ideal lifestyles so that
was the first book and that's it's been
out for almost ten years now and still
usually top 200 on Amazon the next book
for our body came back to my roots
the wrestling roots basically and it
looked at physical performance right so
I did experiments in every possible way
whether it was maximal strength
sprinting NFL Combine holding my breath
with David Blaine sleep sex you name it
sleep sex go back to that part so sleep
I studied people friends of mine who'd
been able to get by four years on two to
two and a half hours of sleep a day by
splitting their sleep up into something
called polyphasic sleep including matt
mullenweg super cardona's of matt
mullenweg who runs a billion-dollar
company and that was a sex we looked at
a bunch of different aspects so for the
men we look at let's take a few minutes
on that talk about the session it's not
that I'm really concerned about it I
just want to get your take on things
right now so we talked about we talked
about things related to sort of male
sexual health and performance such as
improving testosterone right improving
sperm count uh and so on and then there
were at least two chapters but two
chapters that probably got well they did
get a lot of attention
we're on uh if they're on female yeah
all the guys picked up like on how need
to do it two chapters on everything
related to female orgasm Wow and what
was funny about that chapter is that the
I didn't realize it was right in the
middle the book they're all these vagina
diagrams right it's the book got the
book got yanked out of Costco because
they're all these moms were like I just
also know open up they would just flip
right up and all these vaginas and their
kids just pick what are these mommy and
they're like oh oh they're butterfly
yeah it was it was just chaotic so the
book got yanked attic oh man that is it
no what note now our listeners are all
of wood you know all of them what what
about a female orgasm like what what was
what's in this what's the key yeah
what's the key well the key is the key
is he yeah the key is to start with so
about 50% of women in the u.s. last I
checked are in orgasmic they've not
experienced an orgasm and that can have
a lot of reasons can be have a lot of
explanations whether it's religious
upbringing being the oldest sister is
very common as a pattern and their other
certainly but what's very helpful and
people can look into this
is looking at something called orgasmic
meditation which is basically manual
stimulation of the clitoris without any
sex meaning no penetration so you
separate the sexual act from the orgasm
and you effectively are practicing
mindfulness and an attention to the
sensation of being pleasured and
stimulated for the woman so there's no
performance anxiety in other words you
just say we're going to do this for 15
minutes and you don't have to do
anything you just like focus on your
breath and feeling and there's no sex
you'd have to do anything for me you
have to perform and by removing all of
those pressures and all those
expectations with practice and sometimes
it's the first session these women have
never experienced orgasms experience
orgasms and then there's the technical
piece right so if you look if you want
to get into it so if you're looking set
of directly at the clitoris you have out
one o'clock on that clitoris top
upper-right quadrant is where most women
will be most sensitive
Tim's boy and as a pimp and light
contact though which means like for kind
of pages of paper deep that's it I think
a lot of guys go after like they're
starting to lawnmower that's not not
super effective rubber knuckle yeah what
are you trying to do oh my god
yeah exactly so like the black room so
those are those are some of the things
that are in that chapter that is amazing
that is amazing you know what that to be
honest it that can help a lot of
relationships oh it has ever I know that
you say it's directly saved marriages -
amazing and I got a letter from from
someone Hollywood director pretty
well-known guy who was able to finally
get pregnant with what heating up
anybody's wife got pregnant with a few
of the things from the 4-hour body very
simple stuff and it's foxhole radio let
Tim Ferriss get you pregnant it's
serious 96 we're gonna take a break
we're coming right back one o'clock
ladies we out yes ham radios JD Hogg's
were to Paris that's seven dust seven
dust now all you guys out there
listening right now trying to figure
this out I'm with Tim Ferriss he is the
considered now the
Oprah of audio podcast you can get your
life right now and what's amazing
listening to that song right now which
one his top five songs tell them who
that is
well that is a splinter by seven doesn't
actually used that for a book trailer
that I did for the 4-hour body and
people hear that and they might not
realize the characteristics of the lead
singer he is a black dude with a long
dreads from from Atlanta
see don'tjust homogenize I mean
generalize and their acoustic double
wide album is incredible Wow Fantasia
get that you won't get that listen we
talked about the books we talked about
for our work day for our body talk about
this so and I've always said this with
Ricardo you know I'm late to the to the
party when it comes to podcast when it
comes to Internet when it comes to
social media I struggle with the whole
idea of social media because it goes
against sort of other gets a little bit
what I do is you know being an artist I
didn't know it's weird to see the world
change it's weird to see the world
change where you know I I worked so much
on well there's mystique and then my
daughter oldest daughter dad you get you
can stay you can stay hidden if you want
to they'll forget about you that's what
you mean you know you drop the album do
you wait a couple of years easy today
you better drop our album every six
months or they forget about you so
Ricardo you know young finger on the
pulse of everything huge fan of yours
comes to me and says man you have to
meet this guy he'll change your life you
did change my life but let me ask you
this how did you master this what is the
ingredient or what is or is it just a
blessing what is this how do you become
70 million downloads that means that is
interaction that's not somebody saying
these people are following me this is
going down that's yeah that's usually
two and a half hour interviews too it's
not like a 30-second video click that
submits a commitment I think I think
there are a few ingredients and I'm sure
there was a lot of luck and good timing
involved
certainly but there are a few things
that I very deliberately keep in mind
that I think have been helpful the first
is and you kind of alluded to this
earlier where you know you got a really
strong joke when half the room laughs
and how it doesn't okay so I never write
let's just say my blog has let's just
call it two and a half three million
readers right which at one point was
around the same subscriber base as the
Wall Street Journal I think but
regardless and I write long pieces
they're not short right and when I write
a piece and this is truly audio - I
never write a piece that I hope all two
and a half or three million people will
like I try to write a post that 10% will
love hmm
and then I assume every few months I
will hit everybody right so it's like by
the time I rotate through six or ten
articles each person will get one that
they're absolutely diehard right uh in
love with and they will share that and
on another level when I write I try to
produce evergreen content or when I'm
recording audios so when we were doing
our recording which was three feet from
where we're sitting on the couch I was
trying to ask questions that would
provoke stories and answers and lessons
learned that people could use ten years
from right right so it's not just a
three minute TV interview nothing wrong
with that but asking you about the
latest celebrity news which is going to
be irrelevant six right right it was
trying to search for the timeless and
also trying to focus on really getting
10% to love something even if the other
90% hate it that's right right and I
remember at some point I don't recall
who said it but there was a quote I read
that had a huge impact on me which was
there's no sure path to success but the
sure path to failure is trying to please
everyone Wow Elijah Ashley did you just
hear that
and I'm talking to Elijah national who
incredible writers themselves as far as
the movie and they just sold some
something so with their getting this
nourishment as well and they're also a
few books that have had a very very
helpful impact on my thinking about this
one was very short read it's called 22
immutable laws of marketing and what I
like about it get the old version not
before the internet version right right
like the
version where they're looking at like
imported beer and Airlines that's that's
the one that I like and it just talks
about you know in in other or just say
in simple terms how to create new
categories as opposed to trying to
dominate an existing category Wow right
so yeah it's easier and more effective
to try to create a new category which I
often do through language right so for
instance with the 4-hour workweek I
wrote the book that I couldn't find is
basically the book that I want to find
and the options at the time I went to
the bookstore I was searching for
meaning at all these challenges with
business with entrepreneurship so on and
I could either choose a book that was
how to give up money and why it's not
important how to reuse your toothpaste
17 times or how to build a fortune 500
company with Jack Welch and I wanted
something in between so so I built that
or I wrote that and ended up using this
term that may have existed before but I
hadn't heard it called lifestyle design
so lifestyle design I did not trademark
I did not make any attempt to protect
because I wanted to become part of the
common vocabulary I wanted my own part
of the vernacular right which it has now
that's used by hundreds and thousands
probably hundreds of thousands of people
lifestyle design and it's a category now
since I was first I had that first mover
advantage like I am kind of forever in a
sense the founding father of that
category right and the when I looked at
podcasting I asked myself two things I
asked myself first and foremost how can
I do something that is different from
what is currently out there and let's
make a list of all the attributes like
let's call the 10 20 people who are say
organizers of events related these
things what are their rules and they lay
it out so like okay it needs to be this
you need to have musical segues you need
to have it needs to be 20 minutes or
less or whatever they might be right
whatever the rules are and I would look
at the most common rules then I would
try the opposite hmm and Wow and what I
realized was that if you focus also on
highly tactical actionable bits of
information not abstract then
it's a rarity right now for whatever
reason things tend to get very very
abstract so if I lay out let's say my
cot my common rapidfire our questions
are designed very specifically to be
actionable and therefore shareable and
I'll tell you what I mean by that so if
I ask a person what is the book you've
gifted the most other people what is the
first 90 minutes your morning look like
what is the purchase for $100 or less
that is most impacted your life in the
last six months I ask these questions
there are two aspects of it that make it
very very viral and very valuable well
number one is that people can emulate
and test all of those things the next
day secondly they won't just share the
information they will try those things
and then share the results that they get
from that on social media or elsewhere
and as a consequence of that if I stop
writing completely or if I stop doing
the podcast completely my back catalogue
gets listened to so much right that
there would basically be no drop-off so
not I could take the three years off
right and I wouldn't actually fear being
forgotten right and there are counter
examples so this is the other thing I
always look for I look for counter
examples of people who aren't doing what
everyone else is doing like this is the
first one that comes to mind like Daniel
day-lewis yeah as far as I know that
guy's just these gone he's a phantom
unless he comes out then you're like oh
[ __ ] he want another Oscar yeah yeah it
it there's it's sort of in-between
sometimes because I do look at I do look
at some people that you use it a lot and
sometimes it may it may exhaust them a
little but uh I also look at the the
people who do stay refreshed and I don't
know this either but I know Adele came
out and just smashed you know and so
however many billions of records while
Beyonce it is a you know it's an
onslaught you know which is great as
well uh but it's you know I mean in it
but you also end up in a kind of chicken
or the egg conundrum I think with a lot
of these celebrities because one can
wonder did they sell so many records
because they
big social following or did they get so
many people as a social following
because they were on social media and
focused on their art first right so so I
I'm of the opinion and this is speaking
as a tech investor Pete like I have you
know I have a dog in this fight like I
have a lot to gain by people using
social media I think more artists are
distracted from their most important
work than are helped from for their
important work by satiating speak to the
artist here right now it's Fox already
as serious 96 I want people to really
understand what you're saying because I
overheard an artist who didn't have to
say this that it was more about it was
more about the the machine then then
maybe the art and my thing was I think
you're great at both but if you forget
about the art that machine will fall on
top of you
oh the machine will turn you all right
absolutely talk to him please they need
this one I think if I look at the
writers that I must aspire to be like or
emulate if I look at the artists I most
respect they're very good at shutting
out distractions for a period of time
and doing deep work and you need a
certain degree of isolation I think yeah
in many our blocks of time to connect
those uncommon dots or to create new
dots altogether and those who are
distracted by social media are
increasingly unable to create the
conditions for their best work and it's
not hard to understand why because for
instance there's a book that I haven't
seen but a friend told me about another
writer and it's I think it's called
working on my novel is the name of the
book but it's a collect but it's a
collection of tweets and Facebook posts
from people who should have been working
on their novel Wow all these writers is
that their own writing deadlines but
writers will do anything to avoid
writing so you give them something easy
to do like post on Twitter take pictures
of their food and put on Instagram Lord
they're not going to write and all
you know - uh this is giving I'm not
first of all let me say this I know a
lot of entertainers and I know we're
actually simulcasting on your podcast as
well I want to let people know in your
podcast that I'm doing a little bit of
this craziness because we are doing my
radio show so so I don't want to listen
about what was he screaming and acting
so crazy but but when it comes to social
media I've watched a lot of artists die
yeah because they're so connected to
this that they'll read their comments
and then they'll just they'll they won't
be able to sort of dig out and they
begin to try to please everyone which
goes back to what you said that you
can't please them well exactly and
furthermore I would say artistic death
is creativity by consensus and if you're
looking at your comments to determine
how to steer your creative ship you're
dead before you even get out of the game
and that's that's my opinion I think
that if you look at anything as truly
groundbreaking it went against the tide
it never would have been voted for Wow
if that if you follow my like and I mean
I know why this first thing comes to
mind but like Macklemore and like you
know I store like that yeah if you'd put
that in the machine I wouldn't have
shouted it out would never have gotten
past square one Wow
and some of the writing that you see
that's really innovative I just heard
this book called how to get filthy rich
and rising Asia which is written by a
really smart guy in Pakistan actually
and it's written in a effectively
first-person so it says you wake up with
the side of your head on the mud and
your mother's thatched hut and it's all
you you you it's just so inventive and
if you tried that as his first book
going through a traditional process
never would have worked I don't think it
would never would have seen the light of
day so so my thinking at least and if I
look at my best work and we've all had
well I shouldn't say we let speak for
myself I've had better work and I've
certainly had my weaker work right and
if I look at when those things come to
pass the best work is coming from
periods of deep work where I
purposefully block
our exterior distractions and inputs
right end opinions right right let me
ask you this when I'm on the street and
people come up to me they talk about you
in a na almost not a no in a sense about
an Oprah Winfrey way but almost there's
almost uh not to get in trouble but
you're leading like your people wake up
and I need this Tim Ferriss I need that
uh when meeting when I met Oprah Winfrey
that was she was an incredible light
just like when I see you is an
incredible light coming from but also to
she felt there was an incredible
responsibility because there would be
times where she would be exhausted from
literally carrying the 70 million
downloads you know in a scent
metaphorical for her do you ever feel
that what do you ever feel like whoa I
didn't know that this was going to
happen so I need two parts of this I
need one how you became net what's
what's the ingredient and then two now
that you're here do you feel a certain
different responsibility so part one how
it happened would be I think first
thinking of content in the way that I
described
so trying to hit 10% of the people I can
reach and have them love something as
opposed to as opposed to trying to
please everyone all the time and then I
would say the evergreen focus the piece
that I didn't discuss yet that I think
is important is everyone goes after the
traffic leaders what I mean that by that
is that it could apply to magazines
Kapaa TV they'd say who has the greatest
number of viewers followers etc how do I
get to those influencers and that's the
most crowded Channel and it's going to
be the most difficult because those are
people who are in the limelight at the
peak they're the hardest to contact what
I did in the very beginning which I
think led to the tipping point for the
4-hour workweek in part is that I
decided to go after the thought leaders
the
the traffic leaders paid attention to so
if you look at the people who for
instance but and this is true on this
could be true on YouTube it could be
true on at the time you know this was
nineteen I'm sorry 2007 so blogs I was
looking at blog roles and so on
identified the thought leaders people
were very very smart but weren't they
weren't a compulsive self-promoters they
didn't care about a large audience but
their audience was comprised of these
people who had millions and tens of
millions of readers so I would do things
with them Wow and and those and the
domino effect led to over time a very
very large broadcast capability and very
large following the in terms of the
responsibility I absolutely feel that
you know with great audience comes great
leverage and great influence to is to a
great degree and great responsibility
and for that reason for instance in the
4-hour body there was a chapter on
breath-holding which which was done with
with David Blaine I mentioned and I took
it out of the book because even though I
had all these warnings the audience was
large enough that there were people who
weren't paying attention to the warnings
and if you try to do breath holding in
water you can kill yourself with a
shallow water Blackmon and so I wasn't
prepared at that time to accept accept
that breaking a few eggs to make the
omelet I wasn't prepared to have a
metaphorical blood on my hands right
right and I decided that the the
benefits of having it in the world were
not greater than the risks and
liabilities so I took it out and I do
have to be careful in a sense because if
I say something in a really offhand way
people could take it very literally and
that that's always gonna ask you now now
that I mean man look I've got my life
changed in the fact of like people come
up to me it would blow your mind he'll
tell you it will blow your mind of
people that come up said isn't you've
been blessed by him
how was he were you moved Did you touch
the hem of his garment
I mean it's really on some like
incredible admiration so with this
incredible minefield of every single
thing that you say and then the way the
nature of the beast of America of humans
we want to build them up we say one
thing and we want to rip the chords out
of his podcast how does that how does
that work now or do or do you have an do
you have the ability to go somewhere do
whatever you feel like and no one you
know bothers you and you know well I
think there are a few things that I try
to consider to keep myself sane and also
keep my head from getting too big the
first is I always assume I'm fourteen
minutes into my 15 minutes of fame I
just always try to assume that could you
tell that to some of these up I just
named a right now walking around with
bodyguard I just assume it's never last
forever it of course it's not and so
it's there's an expiration date on it
and that's helpful I think number one
well it's very helpful for savoring the
experience and not constantly looking
forward to bigger and bigger plans
although that's a component I think of a
good strategy the the second is I will
very deliberately force myself and I
will schedule this in advance to take
time off the grid right so for instance
you know I'm going to take this July I'm
basically orchestrating putting systems
in place right now recording things in
advance that I can go off the grid for
four weeks
oh I'm gone and I did that before in
Indonesia no calendar no phone no
internet no email for four four weeks
and it's like taking it it's like taking
a six to twelve month vacation when you
come back that feels good you know
you're like oh my god I didn't realize
like every notification every email
every ping every noise it's just like
having Chinese water torture all day and
then and then then you turn it off and
like I didn't realize I was going
through Chinese water torture
it's an incredible relief and it helps
you with that deep work I was talking
about helps me at least so I so yes I do
very deliberately engineer my life in
such a way that
can take time outside of the machine
because I'm not good at I'm not good at
juggling all the pieces when I'm
surrounded with that noise I need time
out it's ten Ferriss it's it's this is
simultaneously on his podcast and
foxhole radio series ninety six we're
going to take a break and as you know as
you've noticed we are getting nourished
we're getting fed we're going to come
back and wrap up with Tim whatever he
wants to give us to let us know how to
move forward how to get your own how to
get your life together man and yes I
have touched the hem of his garment we
back in a moment
there was an Argentinian track what was
the name of that that was fitted Eko al
Bailey try a sty no chick s that much
that's amazing he's from Buenos Aires
Buenos adding that now you been to these
places I have I got when I did my walk
about to try to figure out my life in
2004 I got got to Panama and a friend of
mine said he she got Argentina because
you can live like a king for pennies on
the dollar
yeah and the most beautiful women most
delicious steak and wine on the land and
I was like alright I'll check yeah I
must go we supposed to look the trip it
was supposed to be a four week trip and
house there for nine months
really I was the wait a minute wait hold
on wait a minute come on Tim you went
there for a week and you ended up nine
months what was it was a love of what
was going on I was bitten by the bug
that was Stanga and I had deliberately
beforehand said I was knocking to
practice tango because I the only
version of tango I'd seen was like Al
Pacino in Scent of a Woman Arnold
Schwarzenegger True Lies I was like I
don't want to do that That's not me
and ended up just becoming obsessed with
it and I went I went to the World
Championship six months later are you
serious semi-finalists yeah what is
going on
Tim break that down to us now we were
talking about podcast where I was
telling you to tango champion in
Argentina the white man goes to
Argentina in here and shuts it down
well you go from Japan you you you get a
chance to take a bath
with Grandma first you move up the bad
food chain then you step in the
Argentine little wine a little steak and
all of a sudden all of a sudden I'm
dancing six to eight hours a day yeah it
was heard of
it was an amazing experience and I had a
fantastic dance partner but the it's all
related to what we've been talking about
so the same way that I've looked at the
testing of assumptions and asking
questions so the things that I learned
in Japan just like some of the things
your grandmother armed you with
it all added up later yeah this ability
to test assumptions I remember in
Argentina I got became infatuated with
tango and I started asking myself what
are the rules that everyone says I
should do what if I did the opposite so
they say you should learn how to lead I
said what if I learn the female part
first
that's a weird step so I learned the
follow first from world-class female
teacher then I looked at competition
footage and what people were teaching
and I said alright what's actually
winning the championships and what are
they teaching and where the gaps what
are the things that are winning
championships like long steps certain
types of pivots that aren't being taught
if I learn those I'll have an unfair
advantage so let me find the teachers
who specialize in those so to this one I
gotta ask where does that come from
where does that type of thinking I think
for listeners who are listening on both
your podcasts and on the rate and on my
radio show where does that is that a
blessed thing that you learn how to do
that I need two parts of this one is
that a blessing into what is a pocket I
think it's I think it's both something
I'm it is blessing in the sense that
I've always liked asking are you a
spiritual person or is there any I I
would consider myself I mean I grapple
with that word a little bit I'm not
religious I wouldn't consider myself
religious but I've had a lot of
experiences in the last few years it
would lead me to believe there some
there's something out there's something
out there yeah what do you think it is
that we have a tallboy this is they do
you to heaven and it's just like a gang
of bathtubs we can bathe in and it is it
is Argentinian women and because I used
to think that heaven was going to be
like just my best looking girl just in
everything I see like everything I saw
was my was was the epitome of what I
thought beauty was and then my favorite
food which is sonic burger so I guess in
heaven is just sonic burger Haut with an
exotic burger just a woman I dig and
you'd be surprised you know
just like I'm just updating signing
burgum got my wings got ketchup on all
kinds of crazy things but what do you
says I'm not necessarily spiritual I get
that but there's a lot of things that
that one would say in looking at you is
spiritual when you see the following and
what you do to a person's psyche what
you do to a person's heart and mind is a
spiritual thing so what do you think is
out there without getting too deep we
don't yeah yeah we did we could get into
crazy town
quickly but I have as I've had some very
profound experiences I'll just you know
what I'll to go out there so yeah I've
had some very unusual experiences
primarily related to use of psychedelics
Wow that in group environments proper
supervision that and this is part of the
reason I'm actually helping to finance
studies at Johns Hopkins right and most
likely UCSF in a couple of research
institutions looking at medical
applications of these things that have
led me to believe that putting putting
death aside what happens after death if
anything like maybe it's lights out
we're worm food or right maybe there's
more but I think right now there are
potentially well there are few things we
could be living in a virtual reality mmm
I think there's a there's a non-trivial
chance possibility that's the case and
second is that maybe that's not a bad
thing third I think there are sort of
parallel existences hmm and you might
call them you know sorrow of it all
exactly exactly so so I do think that
it's possible and then this will
probably be explained by it the
scientific method er through experiments
at some point but right now I can't
explain a lot of what right what I've
seen an experienced firsthand with some
of these these plant medicines so that
that has called into question I love how
he calls it plant to plant medicine it's
called it Elijah had just has just
experienced in plant medicine as he's
walked in you can tell me you tell me
he's chewing that gum some plant
medicines going on on the 101 and pretty
soon he'll disappear in a few minutes in
the experience more plant medicines come
back with a big smile on his face and
the answers to it all and so so that the
the I've always asked questions but
writing and the meeting of mentors like
Buxton has taught me how to ask better
questions and so I am constantly in
search of better questions because
people think they need the answers they
don't need the answers you need the
right questions and the podcast from me
so the the Tim Ferriss show was an
opportunity to take a break from writing
to get better at asking questions
because if you get if you think about if
you think about what thinking is it's a
little meta but it's thinking if you if
you reflect on your internal dialogue is
asking and answering questions in your
own head so if you get better at asking
other people questions you get better at
asking your self questions and that
improves everything so the the Tim first
show is really an opportunity for me to
try to deconstruct world-class
performers like yourself like General
Stanley McChrystal like chess prodigy
Josh Waitzkin Laird Hamilton you know
understand who the king of big wave
surfing because I want to try to find
the commonalities what do these people
have in common so 80 at least 80% of
them have a daily meditation practice
for instance and just as one example and
what are the differences so if I find
somebody who's a morning person wakes up
at five - right and then I meet someone
who writes from 2 a.m. to 5 a.m. I want
to talk about that why that's different
right and it's been an opportunity for
me to hopefully I have these
conversations that are so fun I mean
with people like yourself and others and
I just thought for years oh my god it'd
be so much fun and useful to share this
with my hands Wow
but there was never a recorder Wow so I
started the podcast and the side gig
turned into more than a sidekick man
when I tell you some AZ so here's the
question in everybody's asking now what
is Tim Ferriss do what does Tim Ferriss
do in the morning what is Tim Ferriss do
what does Tim what does the goo see this
is the thing like like like the gurus
and the people that that have this I
call it the blessing I call it the you
know cuz I'm a spiritual person you know
like like my daughter tell you know she
knows the books of the Bible and
everything like that but but when you
see someone who has that shine that on
that unexplicable way to be you're
saying something that any
one could else could say but the way
you're saying it the way you're
delivering in it and it works so what do
you do how or do you listen to all of
these things and sort of enhance your
own routine what are you doing when you
wake up in the one you wake up say man
I'm Tim Ferriss ya [ __ ]
I sometimes I wake I just want to pull
the sheets over my head and stay in bed
I think we all have those mornings cool
but generally yes I do borrow from
everybody yeah and my routine right now
is I wake up I tend to wake up on the
late side because I go to bed late yeah
so I wake up let's just say nine o'clock
beyond the later set for me but if I'm
on deadline alright until 5:00 in the
morning
Wow I'll wake up in the afternoon right
now I'll wake up I will go upstairs I
will have supplements that are better
absorbed on empty stomach I will then
feed my dogs then meditate for 20
minutes so that's that's transit
transmittal meditation but I also could
use the pasta or anything else there are
many different ways to go about it then
I will at the at this moment have
specific type of tea I usually have puer
tea which is a Chinese tea with turmeric
and ginger plus something called MCT oil
which helps your brain quite a bit so it
gives you something to ketones then I do
acro yoga practice so I have one of n so
acro yoga is kind of like a Cirque de
Soleil strength performance typically
with a man and a woman's actually very
similar to tango yeah but it's gymnastic
so I'd be supporting a woman on my feet
or one foot and my hands and they'd be
doing cartwheels and forward spins and
head stands and shoulder stands and
handstands on my hands it's extremely
fun and very good physical training this
is everyday I've got a three table I do
three times a week so I you spend a girl
on your feet three times a week for an
hour but I don't do I need to find me a
little lightweight baby just uh yeah
flip her up around you want to start
with what they would call it tiny that's
a little one oh this is amazing now for
my radio people or Ricardo is showing me
what this is this is amazing what does
it call now acro yoga so you got that
they're listening get go to acro yoga
calm acro yoga just sure if you just
urge acro yoga as a guy named Jason
Nemer who's the co-founder nem ER and
what does this know
but does that give you some sort of
interaction with with female energy or
is it it does it does quite a few things
for me so what what I realized for
myself is that in in a culture such as
our own in the u.s. where we have very
puritanical inclinations and baggage
there's not a lot of physical touch it's
very forbidden and you have to be very
very careful about physical touch but we
are higher primates we need a physical
contact is it is part of our hardwiring
DNA and AcroYoga is a fantastic way to
have sensual contact that is not
necessarily sexual right that makes
sense right
and that gives you I think a charge and
a therapy then is extremely valuable and
hard to produce any other way it's also
very playful and I think it's easy for
me at least to take life too seriously
or take myself too seriously and when
you do an acro yoga half the time you're
making mistakes and falling on each
other and flip it over it's just playful
it's like going back to the playground
and I think as adults it's very easy to
think that serious is meaning being
serious not the radio is the the tone
you have to carry to do big things
whereas I think that if you're always
serious you'll be to it you will end up
being too exhausted to complete the
truly important work right so you have
to use play as a way to rest and reset
now do do I use do I use the girl I'm
dating sure for this or do I just go you
can do both cut out to mugger a I got a
I'm gonna be in the room flipping this
girl upside down I'll be out and bow
down you you could try that depends on
the girlfriend ah but the you are in the
epicenter right here the best AcroYoga
or most of the best AcroYoga instructors
on the planet are near venice in santa
monica wow so you're very you're right
in the hotbed for this well I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna get into that oh and
then what else and what how do you how
do you just like and you love to tango
you let it travel but what make what
makes you a girl like I can't wait for
that
that day what's that that makes you cuz
we got our jobs we do what I think
you're leading the people but
what makes you go like I look forward I
look forward to cheat day so Jay the
cheat day and uh yeah she's she's in
cheat day so let's the seed a so-so
cheat day so I follow diet that was in
the 4-hour body it's called the slow
carb diet and it's it's it's very
manageable you can go out to eat with
people they won't even notice you're
honest on a restrictive diet and it
really helps with losing fat loss very
quickly and building muscle so there
have been many many cases I mean dozens
now people have lost one hundred hundred
fifty two hundred pounds but it's also
very effective for just staying lean and
the component that I think is most
important perhaps or one of the more
crucial is the concept of cheat day and
that means you have six days of
compliance and then you have one day
when you can do whatever you want and I
generally recommend that's a Saturday
and a lot of fans have nicknamed that
fatter day and they'll send me they'll
send me photos of all the crap theory I
want to do this Oh ice cream pizza I
mean I like like yesterday effectively
was my cheat day I was fasting for two
days and I was like you know what this
doesn't feel right and I was about the
sort of the clock struck midnight I was
like okay it's cheat day and I just
demolished the entire hotel tray of
goodies and it was glorious
Oh macadamia nuts covered in chocolate
Oh gummy bears yes
candied ginger and I didn't feel any
guilt because that's the purpose of
cheap taste it looks like the
psychological release valve so that you
make yourself so sick you're like I
cannot wait to get back to my lentils
and beans and chicken because that I
feel terrible and then you can stick
with it and that's how people lose 100
200 pounds as fast as it last but not
least for our listeners we've talked
about so many different things a Long
Island a lung collapse um heat stroke
vulnerable um college uh doing it your
own way
just give us a wrap up of in and I know
it's sort of old school but just it's
sort of telling them taking that person
from where they are right now
because a lot of people when they listen
in they got all kinds people say Fox man
I was having a bad day I did it just
give him a little something man just a
little something from you know to get
him going I would say that you do big
things by starting with the small things
and the way that I view my life people
ask me like what's your five-year plan
ten-year plan I don't have one Wow
because a reliable five ten-year plan is
going to be shooting below your
capability I mean I think that if you
have a really if you build a really
tremendous life for yourself in
retrospect it's going to look very
accidental in many respects and to that
end I try to view my life as two-week
experiments right and by doing that I'm
going to try X for two weeks it's not a
permanent decision you can do anything
for two weeks I'm going to try this low
carb diet for two weeks I'm gonna try
fill in the blank
you know meditating for two weeks I'm
gonna try whatever it might be and you
start to develop a confidence in your
ability to act and change your reality
for you and your family or those you
care about
and people will often ask me like how do
i how do I get confidence how do I get
confidence because then I want to go out
do things like no no you got it reversed
you have to do things small a little bit
bigger medium-sized and large to build
that confidence like the only cure for
lack of confidence is acting and the way
that I find easiest is to treat your
life as a series of two-week experiments
and it's whatever your weakness is
whatever your Excuse might be and what
we've all had excuses that is uses and
it's like whether it's I'm too old I'm
too young I'm not this I'm not that I'm
too this I'm too that whatever it is
there is someone who has felt that exact
same way said the same thing to
themselves
and overcome it Wow and you can find
those people so go out and search for
them Wow and one of the questions I ask
experts all the times like if I'm
looking at someone who's saying ultra
endurance runner and I'll ask that like
who is good at this we shouldn't be
right like I know that you have the
people who are built like spiders who
are sort of blessed with a certain
physique that makes it easier for them
to do this but I want to know like
where's the 250 pound guy
who runs fifty hundred mile races like
is there such a person in the big oh
yeah there's this one guy Wow okay I
want to study him Wow and very super he
is very comic-book superhero always you
think it is at one that soul it is and
but it's a toolkit and I do write about
this toolkit a lot in the 4-hour chef
the last book which is kind of a book on
accelerated learning disguises the
cookbook but it is a toolkit that anyone
can use if you have Google and you speak
English like you are in the 1% like I
have to tell you like you have at your
fingertips everything and you just have
to ask the right questions Wow that's it
Fox on radio series 96 hey listen
everybody out there listening you got
two weeks I'll see you in two weeks you
better have it done we are with the one
the only I joke I kid when I first came
on and said Oprah Winfrey was a white
man but let me tell you something Tim
you your own man and in phone for what
you did what you're doing for everybody
for those 70 million downloads and for
those people that are in the street that
you don't even get a chance to see like
I see they counting on your brother man
keep doing your thing and keep giving it
to us it's Jamie Foxx for Tim Ferriss
Fox on radio sirius 96 let me tell you
something when I die heaven better be
off the chain cuz I'm having a ball
right now serious hey XM 96 we got out
of here Tim Ferriss I've touched the hem
of the garment hey guys this is Tim
again just a few more things before you
take off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me would you enjoy getting a short
email for me every Friday the vent
provides a little morsel of fun before
the weekend and five bullet Friday is a
very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or that I've
been pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read
and that I've shared with my close
friends for instance and it's very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you
will get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy it this episode
is brought to you by wealth front and
this is a very unique sponsor wealth
front is a massively disruptive in a
good way
set it and forget it investing service
led by technologists from places like
Apple and world-famous investors it has
exploded in popularity in the last two
years and they now have more than two
and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in wealth
front so the question is why why is it
so popular why is it unique because you
can get services previously reserved for
the ultra wealthy but only pay pennies
on the dollar for them and this is
because they use smarter software
instead of retail locations bloated
sales teams etc and I'll come back to
that in a second I suggest you check out
wealthfront com forward slash Tim take
the risk assessment quiz which only
takes two to five minutes and they'll
show you for free exactly the portfolio
they put you in and if you just want to
take their advice run with it do it
yourself you can do that or as I would
you can set it and forget it here's why
the value of wealth front is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular
basis but normally aren't great
investing is a marathon not a sprint and
little things that you may or may not be
familiar with like automatic tax loss
harvesting rebalancing your portfolio
across more than 10 asset classes and
dividend reinvestment add up to very
large amounts of money over longer
periods of time wealth front as I
mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront com
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor
the show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get $15,000 managed for
free if you decide to open an account
but just start with seeing the portfolio
that they would suggest for you take two
minutes fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront comm forward slash Tim it's
fast it's free there's no downside that
I can think of this episode is brought
to you by me undies if I'm not going
commando I'm in me Andes I have been
testing these underwear for three to
four months now pretty much every day
and in fact throughout a bunch of my
other underwear this morning and on the
road in the house
they are extremely comfortable they look
good feel good they are made of micro
Modell 2 times softer than cotton as
scientifically tested using the cotton
method sounds very fancy of course and I
get a lot of compliments from the ladies
for these you don't get diaper but you
don't get the tired elastic band they
look great and they have other work for
both men and women checkout my undies
comm forward slash Tim and you can see
everything I've been wearing they're
ridiculous the sublime everything
between including my favorite which is
called out and I would be remiss if I
didn't mention their lounge pants this
is a new thing and I've been wearing
their lounge pants when I record
podcasts I've been wearing them out and
about when I'm walking the dog meeting
people for coffee and they are extremely
comfortable they're made from the same
material as the underwear but some of
them like the blue ones I have have
pockets so you can walk about without
seeming like you're off of your meds
and completely crazy so that is awesome
and if you're not happy with the first
pair you try on I assume that refers to
the underwear they'll refund you
completely and you can keep the Perry
tried on for free but if you're that
kind of person you should be ashamed
because that
disgusting me and these compote / Tim
check it out